hi
my name is jennifer daniel i'm the
expressions creative director
and i'm going to talk to you about how
we encode gender
into technical artifacts such as emoji
working on google's emoji program has a
large
breadth of interesting aspects of my job
it includes reviewing emoji proposals
designing emojis
and the experience using them it means
working with teams
all across google like the fonts team to
innovate on the font technology
or with gboard to improve search
prediction and suggestion
if you're running the latest software on
your phone there's over
3000 emojis
in each one of those goes through a
rigorous
process to be to really
land on your keyboard i'm going to talk
quickly about
one proposal that came across our desk
not too long ago for
a not emoji
not a not emoji
okay sure when reviewing the proposal a
large part of my job is
to anticipate is this something that
people are already using
that warrants a multiplication is this
something
that will be frequently used uh and
the proposal talks about some fairly
reasonable examples like um people tie
knots when they sail
the knot is an often used metaphor to
talk about
marriage like tying the knot
however what the proposal doesn't get
into
is how the knot has become emblematic of
other things
for example when paired with an emoji
such as a tree
it can communicate something like
lynching or suicide
my job as a designer is to sort of not
just anticipate those problems
but demonstrate how design can truly
change
the function of something like creating
a knot that's more colorful or a
different style of knot that has less
negative connotations
my job and emoji didn't start too long
ago maybe about
in 2018 or so and it didn't start with
this
but this is when i really started
investigating
how we encode gender into
technical artifacts such as emoji and it
was when i texted a friend
in a meeting love a good mansplain woman
facepalming
and she on her phone received
love a good mansplain but with a man
facepalming
now even though both of these emoji are
technically the same
since they mapped to the same code point
they were rendering
in different genders and this creates
all kinds of cross-platform
inconsistencies like
this is an emoji for a person in steamy
room
what is that man doing there i do not
need to see him i am
alone i'm trying to be peaceful in my
steam room
it turns out this happens a number of
times
i send you a mer person from my pixel
device
and you get a merman on your iphone you
send me
a dead zombie on your iphone and i get a
dead lady on my android device so what's
happening here
well basically vendors such as apple and
facebook and google and samsung
have given gender designs for emojis
that aren't supposed to be explicitly
gendered
and this creates a number of problems
when there aren't even inconsistencies
for example construction worker which is
not supposed to be male or female
everyone has designed to be male
reinforcing a stereotype
unnecessarily or police officer
not policeman not policewoman again
everyone's designed as male
however once you get to the more
emotional gestures
they all default to female person
pouting
person frowning and person shrugging
are all women and this is deeply
annoying
and stupid so how did
we get here well first you must
understand that emoji are part of
unicode
what is unicode they're a standards body
that encodes the world's languages
unicode to put it simply says that here
are characters on a list
this is what they mean this is what
their names are
and this is how they map between legacy
encodings and a universal character set
so unicode has a subcommittee to
standardize these pictograms which i
serve on
and now true to emoji's name emoji are
defined
by two attributes the picture the user
sees on the screen
and second the code that defines it and
unicode's job is to create that code and
those guidelines
however unicode only makes
recommendations
they don't actually decide what the
letters or punctuation really looks like
right that's up to font designers
and so now we have this cacophony of
different
saxophones you look at apple's design
they tend to design their emojis
very very realistically perhaps as a
holdover from the company's early days
in skeuomorphic design
whatsapp emoji are effectively
cheap knockoffs of apples microsoft
embraces a more
flat design due to their font technology
and google's designs
are more cartoonish
and squishy
the moon emoji is probably my favorite
example of how
these different design approaches can
really change
the meaning of an emoji right so this is
the moon emoji
it's a crescent moon pretty
self-explanatory
but it's so much more than that lg
has a septum piercing
facebook's looks like a little bit of
cheese
microsoft reminds me of a rotten banana
and twitter's is a toenail
emoji design has evolved quite a bit
from the 90s
when it first became popular this shift
in
creating designs to show off retina
screens has really left a critical part
of what made emojis useful in the first
place
emojis are no longer like letters and
words like the drink emoji this is a
great example of it the original drink
emoji was just
the idea of a drink right but
now as designers sort of
fetishize the design of what
a martini looks like it is it's no
longer a drink emoji it's a
a dirty martini one olive straight up is
a very
very specific type of drink and when you
get
more specific and more detailed
it begs the question well now we have a
martini what about
a glass of whiskey or tropical drink or
beer
and over time sure enough
we now have a full bar available
in our keyboards this isn't a trivial
new direction for emoji
when a design removes as much detail as
possible it
effectively it conveys the idea of it
rather than
literally reproducing reality so i'm
just gonna have a brief moment of
silence
for the original gender inclusive emoji
the blobs what are they i do not know
emojis really could have gone in two
directions in the early days
android had these little blob characters
which are
neither animal nor human
uh ageless and
broad and apple went into a direction
that was
a lot more specific the original emoji
were simple and abstract and gender and
race
were reasonably obscured however in the
hands of some designers in california
these early design decisions radically
changed the trajectory for unicode and
emojis
as emojis were designed with more
explicitly caucasian and gender
signifiers
we started to see cracks in the system
despite unicode guidelines to remain
neutral
police officers designed as a man and
when five skin tone variants were
encoded
apple changed their defaults from
caucasian to gold
but gold is effectively just another
version of a cartoon white character
and so here we are now 2020
opting for more detail instead of less
and that's how our adorable emojis
evolved from
the concept of a kiss to heteronormative
representations of gender and sexuality
however over the past couple of years
we've managed to convince others to
start to unsex these emojis
what's particularly interesting to me
here is google
made this mistake and corrected it then
made the same mistake again
and then tried to correct it again it's
just
sometimes progress is reversing legacy
decisions
so now there's this unicode document
it's known as it's like tr 251 it's
sort of like the emoji bible and it
provides guidance
to how to implement emoji regarding
gender it states
other than the above list shown here
human form emoji should normally be
depicted in a gender-neutral way
unless gender appearance is explicitly
specified
and that's all fine and good until you
realize
that as of unicode 11.0 63
of the 87 emoji were defined as gender
inclusive
but most vendors did not have unique
designs
for these glyphs these are the only 11
emoji
that everyone supports in a gender
ambiguous design
child adult older person snowboarder
angel baby skier person in bed
fencer person and bathtub and horse
racer
so let's take a look at these guys for a
second most of these emojis are unique
in that they blissfully exist without
male or female partners meaning
there's no baby girl angel
or man in bathtub it's just person and
bathtub
and just angel
however there are three child adult and
older person
that do have male and female partners
and this is really interesting because
it indicates that people are trying to
operate
within a spectrum of gender rather than
subscribing to a false binary
and that makes me optimistic however as
of emoji 12.0
the only designs that apple supported
were for those 11 previously mentioned
emoji
all the other emoji that was supposed to
be gender inclusive
were not this was true of microsoft
this was true of facebook this was true
of twitter
samsung it explicitly like has also
supported gender inclusive superhero and
super villain
i don't quite know why but i suspect
it's because
most of their features were heavily
obscured which made making a design
a little bit easier like a like a baby
step
google wasn't too far off either like
google did not support most of these
and it did support an additional few
focusing mostly on families and couples
ux plays a large role here as well right
apple's keyboard their emoji keyboard
reinforces this false binary by only
displaying
male and female emoji but google's
keyboard
also had problems where they may have
only showed one single gender in the
keyboard but because some of the designs
were explicitly male
and others were female there was this
arbitrary mishmash of genders
so how did we address this poor
implementation
the visual design played a big role some
emojis simply required
a change in hairstyle or clothing color
others required more refinements like
accessories props and body language
and others really forced us to look each
other in the eye
and think deeply about gender
now many have argued that these emoji
representations don't offer us much
visually
however we can't avoid gender any more
than culture can and you have to stare
really in the face to understand it
and so that's what we're trying to do
we're trying to find what are the
signifiers that make something feel
either male or female or both male and
female
gender after all it's a construct so
when exploring signifiers that have
potential to communicate this ambiguity
it's important to remember that gender
lives dynamically on a spectrum
and there's no single visual design
solution and giving ungendered emojis a
gender inclusive appearance
really isn't trivial gender inclusive
designs are intended to represent a
person of any gender
you could argue that a gender inclusive
design works if
the gender inclusive artwork is truly
ambiguous to the viewer
but due to each individual's own
perception of ascribing gender it's
possible
some people look at the existing male
emoji designs and see
woman with short hair or look at the
female emoji design
and see man with long hair so where does
that leave us
are there signifiers that can provide
clues which don't rely on the binary
like
haircut or clothing or color or body
language or other facial features
what level of detail is too much or not
enough because emojis really demand
an instant read contextual clues do
influence perception professions
associated with one gender more than the
other
can impact your perception but what
about
if you're dead what's your gender if
you're a part of the undead
and that's kind of the point context is
king with emoji after all
emoji with contextual elements are most
effective in clarifying our meaning
provided there isn't something that's
contradicting it or conflicting it that
isn't present
the least misconstrued smiley emojis are
frequently embellished
with popular interpretation aids such as
hearts or
tears or dominant upturned or downturned
mouths
so while yes hair is one factor other
things like clothing and accessories can
inform perception
given how fluid and dynamic language and
gender presentation can be
it's not inconceivable that regardless
of haircut shirt collar
accessories other clues gender inclusive
emoji could be
repurposed in some other manner like
prince
princess emperor head of state
and because i work at google i really
wanted to understand
how google search interprets images as
it relates to gender
a researcher at google had been
exploring what happens when you apply a
makeup classifier to an image
and what features change in that image
so i took
the image she generated and just put
them through google image search results
so you see this this image of a
prototypical we might call a man
right uh google image sent back
possible related search gentlemen i was
like okay google image search gets it
they get that this is a picture of
a man so ran the next image through
and it changed it to boy super
interesting okay so what happens when we
run the next image through
oh it shot that boy again okay no change
there
got a little excited then the fourth
image also
reads back boy maybe maybe this
experiment will get me nowhere but i ran
the fifth one through
and it changed a girl and the next one
also became girl the last one
returned models with bleached brows so
we're getting somewhere interesting as
it relates to what the makeup classifier
is changing
but also that there is the spectrum of
interpretation not just in gender but
also in age
so tackling the first phase of using
gender inclusive designs
for code points which do not specify
gender is pretty clear
support existing code points that do not
have
gender so this was google's
emoji font set in 2018
and this is here it is in 2019 fully
compliant
to unicode guidelines so now when you
text someone
i feel so relaxed
you don't have to worry you can feel
relaxed
when we launched these the reception was
enormously positive
people finally feeling like they felt
like they didn't have to choose between
two genders anytime they just wanted to
simply express
some joy
most of the gender inclusive emoji
rolled out in 2019 although some rolled
out in 2020 as well and we're seeing
much wider adoption
there's been rapid development as major
vendors such as apple
roll out their designs and twitter as
well
the experience around selecting these
emojis seems to be a work in progress
apple has chosen to simply add the third
option alongside male
and female designs google has opted for
one design to be the default
asking people to opt into their gender
this also makes it
room so much easier to just browse your
keyboard
for the right emoji because there's
there's less redundancy
but now comes the hard part what to do
with the 12
explicitly gendered emoji okay
man in tuxedo this is fairly simple
we make it a person in tuxedo we add
support for women in tuxedo and man
tuxedo
now we have jane bond jesse bond and
james bond
that seem logic can apply to woman
person
and man in bail but what do we do
about mrs claus and santa claus
we get mixed claws now i know you're
thinking
there's no such thing as mix clause but
there's also no such thing as santa
claus
now the breastfeeding emoji did stump
the group a bit
do we simply change the existing design
for this code point
to remove it from the explicitly
gendered list
and then we can if so desire add
additional sequences for men
and women well the general consensus was
people did not feel comfortable changing
the woman breastfeeding emoji to be more
inclusive
and since we don't use sex signifiers to
denote gender
the presentation in our designs we're
really unable to settle on a reasonable
fallback
and opted instead to create an entirely
new emoji
man woman and person feeding baby the
logic being simply that
since the only emoji that depicts anyone
with child care was breastfeeding
there just really weren't any emoji that
really expressed nurturing your child
in my opinion though parenthood is
already representable
with a tornado and a pile of poop
and you know people one of the things i
do try to think about
is how this emoji is being used and how
it will be used and so finally we do
have an appropriate father's day emoji
other emoji like bearded person
are clearly designed in a way that's
more masculine
moving forward bearded person will be
shown in a more
inclusive manner but what to do
about bearded women and bearded man
beards have long been indiscriminate of
gender throughout history
and truth be told this isn't really
about women with beards or
men with beards it's more of a question
of do people with long hair have beards
and the answer is yes right anyone you
watch eurovision
there's a great number of men and women
with long hair and beards in the world
and many that are very cultural relevant
which is why these resolutions can be
complex we can't simply change the
design of existing emoji
anytime culture changes so we have to
anticipate not just where we are now
but where we will be going the flamenco
dancer
she's iconic she's really become
something emblematic
of some something so much more than
simply dancing
but if you really go back and think
about iconography
look at the man bathroom symbol why does
this mean man
and not just person because someone
added a skirt to create a woman design
why would they do that because what
they've effectively done
is reinforced that what would have been
a perfectly acceptable default gender
inclusive symbol
for person is now a man which reinforces
our man-centered society
i don't know what the blobs were they
were just good little friends
and this was the original dancer emoji
in 2013.
it wasn't a woman it wasn't a man it was
a child it wasn't an animal
it was just a dancer
and you know 2015 phones get fancier
details get added and now we have these
fairly sexualized dancers and
in their specificity and detail
they have alienated a great deal of
other kinds of dance what about african
dance polynesian dancing or boogie
woogie
and in 2019 we see something that
is really fun but when you're thinking
about encoding emoji and putting
broad concepts that cover the concept of
dancing
not specifically flamenco dancing paying
attention to those details is really
important
that i digress like what do we do what
do we do about woman flamenco dancer
and man disco dancer we don't have
something that just conveys
the concept of dancing we are not going
to change
the existing code points this is not a
path forward we want to move forward
with
so what if we added a third type of
dance for the gender inclusive like
um this you know be provocative here's a
breakdancer
but it seems appealing right but is it
future proof like will we still be happy
with this
gender inclusive type of dance
five years from now two years from now
10 years from now
will this create more problems in the
future or less
in my mind if we get gender inclusive
break dancing emoji
why don't we have it for feed for women
and for men as well
so another possibility is to just simply
design
male and person counterpoints the
flamenco dancer
and women and gender inclusive character
points to the disco dancer
but do we really need this many flamenco
dancers on our keyboard
and this many disco dancers probably not
another emoji that is being discussed
is the pregnant woman emoji one sex
doesn't really dictate the capacity to
care
for in the home or at work or in the
market right
so if you look towards sex equality law
that aims to combat harmful sex
stereotypes it has a lot of parallels
with how we're unsexing pregnancy and
how it could do the same for parenthood
so let's take a look at how we would
unsex the pregnancy emoji
the british medical association's
guidance on inclusive language
advises advice people to use the term
pregnant people instead of a stereotype
term pregnant women
why because though a large majority of
people who have been pregnant or have
given birth identify as women
there are intersex men and trans men who
may get pregnant
so we've decided instead of changing the
existent pregnant woman emoji
to simply add a swollen belly to
a person design and a swollen belly to a
man design
this is very similar to what we did with
the bride in the groom
however much like the flamenco dancer
and much like the flamenco dancer
there was a strong desire not to correct
the legacy decision
to double down on pregnant women but now
we finally have that emoji for when
you're hungry
right like you have eaten that burrito
what emojis can you use to employ about
how full you are
sure a burrito and a tongue emoji
but that's not really that that feast
looks more like i'm hungry not that i am
i ate too much but now with swollen
belly
you finally have the perfect emoji for
lunchtime
language emerges from human minds
interacting with each other it's it's
visible in the unstoppable change we see
through
slang and jargon and the formation of
new languages like texting
and what i love about this program is
that it forces me to zoom out of my tiny
world
and realize that we're in the middle of
the story and we're not at the beginning
and we're not at the end
as google and others roll out more
ambiguous and inclusive designs for code
points that don't specify gender
a significant acknowledgement is
happening our emoji are moving away
from heterosexuals other default to here
are two people
here as a family the beautiful thing
about language
is how it evolves words don't stand
still like formal writing it's like
water it's fluid
and unicode's waters are still but they
are very very deep
so i just want to say thank you for
watching i've really enjoyed exploring
this with all of you
and
have a great day